sie versüßt ihr die weihnachtszeit
du siehst du wieder zugeschneit dich mit
packen vom alltag gefreut
ich mit weiten von alten frau
das ist
das ließ
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es wieder eine leckere torte
der murat der liga total marzipan und
deswegen hat er sich auch dieses jahr
wieder eine leckere marzipantorte
gewünscht und die werde ich jetzt heute
machen
ganz unten ist ein knuspriger mürbeteig
dann kommt eine schicht biskuitteig und
gefühlt witze mit einer haselnuss fahne
und später dann auch noch schön
dekoriert und ich starte jetzt zuerst
mit dem web zeigt der muss dann nehme
ich noch ein bisschen in den kühlschrank
und danach mache ich den biskuit teig
also an zutaten brauche ich 140 gramm
mehl 90 gramm kalter butter 45 gramm
zucker 1 eigelb und etwas salz so jetzt
kommt einfach alles in die
küchenmaschine ihr könnt den teig auch
mit den händen verkneten
aber das solltet ihr dann ganz schnell
machen denn der teig muss er ganz kalt
bleiben
jetzt kommt zuerst die butter rein
danach der zucker alles und das frühere
ich jetzt kurz durch
jetzt gebe ich auch direkt schon mal das
mehl mit rein flugzeug ist man ganz
schnell dateien und auch das eigelb mit
muss ich einfach nur noch alles schön
verbinden
den teig gebe ich jetzt auf eine silikon
matte und können dann noch mal kurz
zusammen kneten
jetzt gebe ich den tag hier auf eine
back folie habe ich jetzt einen
tortenring ausgerufen habe den auf 26 cm
eingestellt und da reden wir da jetzt
ausgebreitet
den teig sich jetzt mehrmals ein zog
jeder beim backen nicht auf und gibt
bleibt gleichmäßig flach
den teig stelle ich jetzt erst mal kurz
in den kühlschrank damit er noch mal
schön kalt wird und in der zwischenzeit
bereit ich schon mal den biskuit teig
vor film bis geteilt braucht der vier
eier dann habe ich hier auf das eiweiß
ist weiß noch vom eigelb von vorhin
übrig so kann man es einfach mit
verwerten
120 gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt
eine prise salz 4 esslöffel heißes
wasser ich habe ich 75 gramm mehl und 75
gramm speisestärke zwei teelöffel
backpulver und 50 gramm gemahlene die
happen haasis habe ich bringt selbst
gemacht die mich zuerst teja in die
rührschüssel da kommt auch das eiweiß
mit dazu dann muss man das nicht
irgendwie anhalt verwalten sondern kann
sie agenten geben etwas vanille extrakt
als und dann auch den zucker direkt mit
rein und es wird jetzt erst mal drei bis
vier minuten krieges gewinnt
zwar kommt auch direkt mit rein lassen
sich die eier aufschlagen
die masse ist es schön schaumig und
cremig und finde es immer wieder
erstaunlich wie voluminös vier jahren
kann das echt unglaublich
also sollte es dann auch in etwa
aussehen
jetzt habe ich hier bereits backpulver
mit speisestärke und mehl vermischt das
wird jetzt darüber gesehen dann noch die
haselnüsse
die können da vorher zum beispiel in der
pfanne anrösten
dann entwickeln sie noch mehr so ein
haselnuss aroma und wer möchte könnte
jetzt auch ein rennen haselnuss likör
oder an sirup mit dazu geben dann
schmeckt eben noch mal intensiver jetzt
hab ich die zutaten noch unter
jetzt will ich den teig in meine
vorbereitete springform da habe ich
jetzt bereits die springform auf 26 cm
eingestellt
und so wie der teig jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad für
ungefähr 25 minuten gepackt der bis bis
jetzt gepackt und jetzt kann auch der
methoden bei 200 grad für ungefähr neun
minuten in den backofen die tortenböden
sind jetzt beide abgekühlt und ich habe
auch schon aus der form herausgelöst und
jetzt bereits noch die füllung zu und
dafür habe ich mir eine haselnuss dana
ausgedacht deswegen habe ich jetzt hier
bereits 400 gramm kalte schlagsahne habe
ich 275 gramm frischkäse ihr könnt auch
200 nehmen aber in der packung
philadelphia neben 175 250 gramm
magerquark 50 gramm puderzucker
hier habe ich 100 gramm gemahlene
haselnüsse seiner fahrt und ich brauch
noch etwas konfitüre da habe ich jetzt
so eine schwarz kirsch konfitüre mehr
ausgesucht so als erstes setzt sich
jetzt mal den mürbeteig boden auf eine
tortenplatte
als nächstes schneide ich jetzt ein
bisschen boden durch der sie zwar noch
ziemlich frisch ist zwar abgekühlt aber
am besten lassen sich bis mit böden am
nächsten tag schneiden aber ich probiere
das jetzt trotzdem
jetzt nehme ich die zwei oberen böden
mit einer tor mit einem tollen reck
und jetzt streiche ich etwas von der
konfitüre auf dem mac boden dann klebt
der bis mittag gut drauf
da kommt jetzt der unterboden drauf und
dann noch eine schicht von der konfitüre
da kommt jetzt einen tortenring außen
rum da kann ich die torte gleich gut
gefühlt und jetzt stelle ich sie kurz
zur seite und kümmere mich um die
füllung
zuerst muss ich jetzt mal die sahne
steif schlagen da gebe ich dann
währenddessen vier teelöffel seiner park
mit rein
hmm
und jetzt habe ich die sahne bereits
kühl gestellt damit sich im zimmer warm
wird und jetzt kann ich die restlichen
zutaten hier noch kurz
also ich habe jetzt hier frischkäse
quark butter zucker da gebe ich auch
direkt die haselnüsse mit rein und auch
hier 15
und wer jetzt in hassels geschmack noch
verstecken möchte kann jetzt hier noch
etwas haselnuss sirup oder haselnuss
league herbe 3 geben
und jetzt kann ich die steif geschlagene
sahne und hat die creme heben
jetzt völlig circa ein drittel der creme
hier direkt mit rein
verstreicht mit der winkel palette
dann kommt der zweite boten drauf
das zweite drittel der creme und dann
kommt der deckel drauf
und jetzt kommt auch die restliche creme
drauf
ich habe jetzt schon etwa drei esslöffel
der creme aufgehoben um später den rand
noch ein bisschen zu bestreichen und
jetzt denke ich die torte ab und sie
muss erst mal für mindestens 12 stunden
den kühlschrank bevor es dann gleich
weitergehen kann
die torte ist schön kalt jetzt kann ich
den torten rand entfernen
das mache ich jetzt auch mit einem
paletten messer also mit dem trockenen
jetzt schreibe ich noch etwas von der
übrig gelassenen creme an den rand
selbst die torte noch mal kurz im
kühlschrank gestellt und werde jetzt
schon mal die dekoration vorbereiten
dafür habe ich jetzt hier marzipan und
zweites modell ihr marzipan
ich hab da nämlich einen höheren
zuckeranteil stadt mandl anteil
und zwar deswegen damit ich es eben
später gleich modellieren kann und damit
kann ich jetzt perfekt arbeiten und kann
es direkt ausrollen und muss eben nicht
noch puderzucker einknicken und das
marzipan gibt es in verschiedenen farben
und ich habe jetzt für blau entschieden
denn meine torte wird gleich
weihnachtlich blau mit sternen und im
engel und deswegen denke ich passt das
ganz gut jetzt nötig das marzipan kurz
durch und zum ausrollen nehme ich hier
auch wie bei vom bäcker stärke
ich hab das marzipan jetzt ganz groß
ausgerollt also ein bisschen größer als
der durchmesser der torte
jetzt geht es am besten wenn ihr den auf
den aus hollstadt auf gold dann komplett
orte
jetzt kann ich es einfach drüber
ausrollen und ich habe denn jetzt so
etwa 3 mm dick ausgerollt den würde ich
mal nicht ausruhen
m
zum glätten auch hier wieder eine vom
land kirche
ich werde jetzt die torte noch fertig
dekorieren dafür modell ist gleich einen
engel und der größe noch mit sternen und
ja so ein bisschen mit weiß und mit geld
und dafür nehme ich jetzt auch ein
fachmann macht die komplette dekoration
auch aus marzipan
die dekoration klebe ich jetzt mit etwas
wasser an
für den engel pharmig jetzt ausweis
zuerst eine kugel und daraus dann einen
kegel
die ränder drücke ich nach unten flach
so entsteht ein schönes kleid dann
stecke ich einen tag stehe rein da kommt
später der kopf drauf und dann stelle
ich noch den kragen blumen für mich aus
m
und wer möchte kann jetzt das weiße
kleid noch mit weißem kristall pulver
etwas befördern
aus gelb großer braun und weiß mich
jetzt die hautfarbe zusammen für den
kopf
jetzt warum ich den kopf und steckt ihn
dann auf das stäbchen drauf
mit einem schwarzen lebensmittel stift
mag ich jetzt noch die augen auf
mit einer tülle könnt ihr den mund
formen
und mit roter pulver fahren können jetzt
noch die wangen aufmalen
die flügel lege ich jetzt noch zum
trocknen auf einen runden gegenstand
jetzt müssen wir noch die haare geformt
werden dafür nämlich gelb forme lange
strenge und zwirbeln sie dann in sich
ausweis vor mich jetzt noch den
heiligenschein und pinsel ihn dann mit
etwas kristall pulver farbe
die flure ich lebe ich jetzt mit etwas
zucker kleber an
zum schluss setzte ich jetzt noch den
engel drauf den könnt ihr gerne zum
beispiel auch ein abend vorher machen
dann trocknet ein bisschen durch und ich
würde den engel dann erst kurz vor dem
servieren draufsetzen
denn der ist ja schon ein bisschen
schwer dass er nicht in die torte
einsinkt und ja so ist es meine torte
vettweiß eine ganz schnelle torte eine
ganz einfache torte und dennoch eine für
hübsche torte und jetzt kann sie dem rat
gleich probieren
jetzt weist die torte an das gespann
beispiel von marzipan fan ich war es
deswegen habe ich jetzt auch die ganze
dekoration nur aus marzipan gemacht
also ich finde es schon mal richtig gut
aus und ich denke sie schmeckt auch so
gut ich habe jetzt diesen map pack boden
mit der schwarz kirsch marmelade mit der
konfitüre und eine haselnuss creme und
jetzt nochmal richtig schmeckt wie so
ein video joghurt ja ich finde es riecht
auch so also durch diesem quark und
frischkäse und hat mal eine richtig
schöne creme genial und man hat jetzt
diesen kuchen zum beispiel auch mit
modell ihr schokolade überziehen können
aber es geht etwas schwieriger weil das
mag zwar etwas weicher man kann es
einfach geschmeidiger darüber lägen mit
von dann klappt es übrigens nicht weil
sondern sich auflöst auf seine krems
deswegen fand ich jetzt was machen
einfach die beste lösung
bei uns sind vor allem geschmacklich
halt ein sehr guter start ist genial
möglich freut mich lief jetzt möchte
eurodrive ja vielleicht fällt es ja noch
einen kampf zu uns in die kommentare
schreiben
auf jeden fall können sie dieses rezept
auch gerne nachmachen
das schreibe ich euch nochmal auf salehs
- blog.de ich finde wirklich die arbeit
mit marzipan als mit diesem modell
erwarte kann wirklich sehr einfach und
vor allem sehr angenehm also man muss
nicht lange kneten und hat dennoch ein
schönes ergebnis
genial richtig toll und den marzipan
engel kann man auch gut auf essen
schmeckt aber erst noch foto also viel
spaß und nachmachen und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal
ich weiß es wird noch
nachdem einige gut nachdem nachdem mit
dem hasen und geschmack laut steer
eingefangen wahnsinn wirklichkeit
trotzdem in die kommentare
wahnsinn